c'est lui à tous c'est christophe pour
la chronique politique aujourd'hui on va
parler de l'imam radical hassan
iquioussen plus tôt on va le laisser
parler de lui même alors pour ceux qui
n'ont pas suivi la situation est bien
hassan iquioussen c'est un imam radical
présent en france depuis de nombreuses
années qui a la particularité d'être né
en france mais d'avoir refusé la
nationalité et donc pour résider sur le
territoire il a besoin d'un titre de
séjour que qu'il a été dans le renouveau
réellement il a été refusé cette fois
par par l'état au nom est bien des
valeurs de la république puisque kivu
scène est considéré comme étant un imam
radical il est de fait comme on va le
voir dans les extraits proche de la
galaxie des frères musulmans il serait
faire lui-même d'ailleurs aux fondateurs
de cette galaxie qui est hassan al banna
et donc l'état décidé de ne pas
renouveler son titre de séjour au nom de
ces valeurs puisqu'il est dit très
clairement que iquioussen ne respectent
pas les principes de laïcité est
également notamment les questions
d'égalité homme-femme dans ses prêches
et donc ils tuent scène depuis quelques
jours se mobilise et mobilise autour de
lui la sphère de la gauche identitaire
de la gauche
indigéniste qu'on peut aussi appeler
extrême droite identitaire d'origine
arabo-musulmane le terme serait plus
exact et maintenant réussi aussi comment
a mobilisé une partie de la gauche type
france insoumise puisque certains
députés de la france un sur dix ont
publié des communiqués de soutien à cet
imam
également c'est le cas de de la ligue
des droits de l'homme qui a aussi fait
un communiqué de soutien
donc aujourd'hui je vous propose de
découvrir l'idéologie et bien d'hassan
iquioussen par lui même alors tout
d'abord quelques remarques la chaîne
youtube dasani pius n compte 170 vidéos
dont certaines font une à deux heures
donc j'ai pas tout regardé c'est évident
et j'ai pioché dans les vidéos qui me
semblait pertinent par leurs thématiques
des moments qui qui me semblait
pertinent et refléter sa façon de penser
donc ce que vous allez voir c'est un
condensé mais ce n'est pas une
caricature d'eux de ses propos
d'ailleurs vous pourrez le voir je
laisse de très longues très longues
séquences ce qui fait que cette vidéo là
au total de faire 45 ou 50 minutes 1
pour ne pas troquer ses propos il
laisser développer c'est
ses propos surtout que c'est quelqu'un
de très volubile qui prend beaucoup de
temps pour parler
ce qu'il faut comprendre donc c'est que
les vidéos viennent de sa chaîne youtube
l'équipe donc reflète ce que lui veut
montrer et bien de lui même auprès du
public
alors dans ces vidéos que j'ai
sélectionné dans ces extraits il ya
quelques éléments qui n'apparaissent pas
par choix personnel it yourself et
notamment beaucoup de vidéos sur la
question de l'islamophobie alors je n'ai
pas traiter cette partie vous ne verrez
pas d'extrait sur cette question là pour
un choix personnel qui est que
je ne supporte plus ce concept
d'islamophobie très clairement qui est
pour moi en fait une forme d'incitation
à la haine raciale à la haine de l'autre
qui se pare des habits de la victime
parce que quand on regarde en france on
a quand même des attentats islamistes
depuis 2015 et on a encore pendu aucun
musulman un lampadaire on a eu aucun
pogroms et quand on compare avec ce qui
se passe pour les minorités non
musulmanes dans les pays musulmans 1
allez regarder ce qui se passe notamment
au pakistan on se dit que quand même
clairement la notion d'islamophobie est
une vaste escroquerie intellectuelle
donc pour pas mettre mes nerfs à rude
épreuve par cette période déjà de
canicule je n'ai pas regardé les vidéos
des indics hussein qui parle d'
islamophobie
donc c'est un point aveugle deuxième
élément dans ces vidéos vous ne verrez
pas ici des extraits sur la question
sur la question israélo palestinienne où
la question de l'antisémitisme
puisque quand il était jeune et q-cells
a eu quelques propos clairement
antisémite dont il s'est repenti et
depuis est beaucoup plus prudent donc il
ya un débat sur son antisémitisme il a
d'ailleurs même lui-même fait une
synthèse de ces propos en vidéo si vous
allez voir sur la question et j'ai
retrouvé à peu près les mêmes propos
dans ces vidéos où grosso modo il fait
la différence entre le peuple juif et
les sionistes ont pour lui les sionistes
et tous ceux qui veulent l'existence
d'israël et pas seulement pas seulement
des juifs donc clairement
pour le dire simplement sur sa chaîne où
il met les choses qui pour le se mettre
en avant j'ai pas vu dans les vidéos que
j'ai regardé et bien de propos
antisémites qui tomberait sous le coup
de la loi on a quelques éléments parfois
un peu tangente des éléments de langage
voilà qui rappelle certaines choses mais
c'est honnêtement ça tombe pas sous le
coup de la loi et si vous êtes de gauche
anti sioniste entre guillemets ça tombe
pas non plus sous le coude de votre
moral
donc je n'ai pas traiter cette question
là dans les extraits que vous allez voir
néanmoins donc faut toujours se rappeler
que qui s'est mis en avant ce qu'il veut
bien mettre en avant parce que quand on
creuse à côté on vers un extrême il fait
un petit peu le l'éloge de soral on peut
aussi trouver sur internet qu'il a fait
une conférence justement avec alain
soral vous avez des frères 10 kg ou
scène qui tient la mosquée avec lui et
qui fait aussi des vidéos sur leur
chaîne youtube qui a été pris en photo
au sénat en train de faire une quenelle
donc assez significatif donc moi là
concrètement tout ce que j'ai vu je n'ai
pas j'ai rien vu d'illégal ou de trop
tendancieux mais il faut bien comprendre
que c'est pas l'intégralité du
personnage et probablement il ya des
éléments voilà ces éléments un peu plus
mis sous le tapis ce qu'itunes est née
quand même quelqu'un d'intelligent c'est
quelqu'un qui fait partie de la sphère
des frères musulmans il serait faire
clairement à hassan al banna à youssef
al qaradawi donc ce sont des gens
qui sont dans cet islam politique qui
sont là pour qu'ils s'intègrent dans les
pays où ils sont donc qui respecte
globalement la loi et ils font un
travail un peu de lobbying en sous-main
auprès des élus ce genre de choses
d'accord donc les propos vous allez voir
de fait
sont toujours dans le cadre de la loi
même s'ils peuvent pas trop conservateur
l'islam politique c'était ni djihadisme
ni ni ce qu'on appelle les
laitiers tistes c'est à dire ceux qui
t'ont en islam radical mais qu'il
pratique au quotidien et qui se coupe
complètement la société extérieure
l'islam politique du quiou scène et des
frères musulmans c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus soft donc si vous vous
attendez à des propos qui appelle au
djihad qui sont clairement
discriminatoire c'est une beaucoup plus
subtil dans cette mouvance là ce sont
des gens qui qui globalement reste
globalement respecte la loi et ça se
voit ça se sent un discours digne ou
scène c'est qu'il avait souvent un
discours une partie théorique radical et
puis après on vous dit il faut dans la
pratique faut modérer c'est quelque
chose que j'avais déjà vu aussi j'ai
tariq ramadan ou de fait avait deux
discours quasiment dans la même phrase
et chacun va adhérer à celui qui
l'intéressent quoi le discours théorique
radical ou le discours plus plus light
que j'ai ramadan c'est eh oui la
lapidation existe mais il faut un
moratoire donc voilà chacun comprendra
ce qu'il veut de la part de ramadan sur
sa position sur la lapidation
également on voit ce
ce côté frères musulmans dans certains
extraits vous allez voir parce qu'il
aime il réinterprète en fait à 180° des
notions
occidentale ça c'est une spécialité de
cette mouvance de l'islam politique ils
prennent des concepts occidentaux et les
déforme complètement ce qui fait qu'on
utilise les mêmes mots mais avec des
significations totalement opposé par
exemple ces gens globalement en dix sont
pour la liberté mais en fait quand on
écoute d'un lisa oui la liberté c'est la
liberté de se soumettre volontairement à
dieu la liberté c'est la soumission
c'est pas exactement la définition qu'on
a on est en occident va vous verrez ce
genre de jeu sur les mots et l'inversion
total a lâché iquioussen notamment que
la définition de la mixité et la
définition de la démocratie
également ce qu'il faut garder en
mémoire notamment si on connaît pas les
milieux d'islam radical quand on écoute
ce que dit bruxelles c'est que donc il
concède c'est un peu la voie moyenne
dans l'islamisme il faut bien se dire
quand vous écoutez ça c'est déjà ça vous
choque dites vous bien qu'il y en a
d'autres dans des mosquées en france qui
tiennent des discours bien plus radicaux
je pense par exemple à
rachid et jake il ya quelques années
disait que ceux qui écoutent la musique
seront transformés en port
clairement ce n'est pas le genre de
discours que vous entendrez cheikh
hussein mais dont ils gardaient bien en
tête que c'est déjà ce qui vous dit sur
l'égalité hommes femmes sur
l'homosexualité sûr sûr sûr toutes ces
choses là ça vous choque pas dites vous
qu'il y en a d'autres qui font bien pire
dans des mosquées en france et qui que
cents avant tout un symbole que l'état
veut un veut dégager
et d'ailleurs cette question de
l'expulsion je pense que l'état à ouvrir
un peu un débat sans le vouloir et une
forte une sorte de boîte de pandore
parce que si aujourd'hui on dégage x y
ou scène à cause de ses opinions
politiques ou religieuses qui sont pas
en phase avec la république et c'est
clair qu'ils ne sont pas du tout en
phase et bien ce qu'elle a ça pose
énormément questions par rapport à bon
nombre de musulmans puisque toutes les
études qu'on a depuis quelques années
d'études sociologiques ou aux études
électorale tout nous montre qu'il ya
quand même une spécificité hausse 1,2 en
france au sein de l'électorat musulman
qui est complètement en décalage par
rapport au reste de la population on l'a
vu récemment il ya un sondage sur
l'avortement où toute la population pour
l'avortement très majoritairement y
compris les cathos je crois que c'est à
80 % qui sont pour l'avortement parmi
les cathos et vous avez ceux
initialement une minorité de musulmans
qui sont pro avortement et ce genre de
décalage se retrouve dans tous les
sondages dans toutes les études qu'on
fait qui montre que les musulmans sont
beaucoup plus conservateur que que la
moyenne est en fin de contrat on regarde
vraiment les questions posées en fait on
s'aperçoit que ben la majorité des
musulmans sont d'accord exclu ce que
vous allez entendre dans cette vidéo des
kew scène et vous voulez plus de détails
également j'ai fait une vidéo sur
récemment sur justement une publication
de fondation jean jaurès qui avait mené
une étude dans laquelle il y avait un
panel de
musulmans franciliens vous verrez leur
position sociétales sont les mêmes que
celles exprimées par paris cusems
donc si on pose si l'état pose la
question de l'expulsion est bien dit yu
scène pour ses opinions politiques et
bien légitimement se poser la question
de ce qu'est ce qu'on fait des millions
de musulmans au moins ceux qui sont à
comparer à la carte d'identité française
qu'est ce qu'on fait de si on est des
gages et hussein il faut aussi les
dégager c'est à dire que là sans le
vouloir darmanin l'état et tout ce petit
monde pose la question involontairement
de la question de l'immigration massive
d'une partie de personnes qu'on n'arrive
pas à intégrer parce que
d'ailleurs les sondages montrent aussi
que les jeunes générations qui devrait
pourtant être intégrés sont aussi des
plus radicales
c'est anne itto passage donc voilà le
débat est ouvert et je vous invite à
même si cette vidéo est relativement
longue à écouter entièrement parce que
je pense qu'il faut au moins une fois on
savait écouter ce qui se dit dans des
mosquées radical au sein de notre pays
voilà sans avoir le filtre des petites
phrases coupées qui voit qu'ils sont
certes rapides à écouter mais qui qui
nous apprennent pas grand chose là avec
les extraits très long que je vous
montre on peut voir un imam radical
développer sa pensée tout ça je pense
que c'est indispensable vraiment de
l'avoir entendu au moins une fois dans
sa vie vu la place que prend aujourd'hui
l'islam dans dans les questions
politiques
bref sur ce et bien je vous laisse nous
si on a plus de pudeur on va faire des
péchés et à ce qu'on va demander le
pardon non et après on veut devenir
comme des animaux on va se comporter
comme des amis on va faire les chances
travail et ça sera normal et naturel on
va même rigolé en faire quelque chose
afin d'en rigoler il y en a qui font ça
dans l'ain qui font des choses horribles
et ils en rigolent ils sont contents d'y
sont fiers
regardez aujourd'hui veut le faire le
mariage pour tous et
toi tu dis est un fleuron là parce que
tu es sensible mais peu y sont plus
sensibles pour eux c'est super c'est une
magnifique c'est la modernité c'est la
liberté
c'est grave c'est pas grave
attendez vous ai encore rien vu dans 30
ans 40 ans qui chanta où sera encore
vivante ça sera le mariage
avec les animaux
pour contrôler
aujourd'hui la ce mariage il ya 40 ans
pour nous c'était impossible
aujourd'hui c'est normal c'est naturel
ils vont voter va vous verrez
dans 40 ans ils vont se marier à une
animaux et n'importe quoi je me suis
trompé pardon pardon
existe déjà demain avec les animaux ça
s'appelle la zoophilie
bien sûr est un rigolo c'est ce qu'il a
fait aux états unis
il a pris rendez vous à la mairie pour
se marier c est qui son cheval
[Musique]
ça s'est passé comme ça aux états unis
vous entendez
pourquoi votre avis font ça parce qu'ils
n'ont pas honte
il se moque même du cerveau et de
l'intelligence
de l'humain je parle même pas de la
morale de l'éthique
donc les filles écoutent et bien nous
sommes dans une société qui pousse les
gens à ne pas avoir de limites ce
prétexte que pour fait ce qu'on veut
c'est faux on fait pas ce qu'on veut
parce que si on fait ce qu'on veut on va
se mettre des animaux demain
et ils vont faire ce qu'ils appellent la
pédophilie et vend la rendre licite
normal et naturel et des exemples comme
ça je m'en sors des centaines et des
milliers
une imbécile n'ya pas longtemps en
france je peux vous dire son nom la
télévision dans une émission bête et
stupide là quand l'appel de télé réalité
c'est ça elle rentre dans la scène et
elle s'est habillée avec quoi avec des
steaks des morceaux de viande
elle a pris des morceaux de viande des
steaks là les attacher les arts et son
vêtement à l'été lui et c'était des
morceaux de viande partout sur son corps
et à le rendre comme ça la télévision
les cas une star une star ça s'appelle
ce que vous rendez compte la viande des
steaks sur un corps nu de femme devant
la caméra devant des millions de gens
pourquoi elle fait ça
non c'est pas seulement pour gagner de
l'argent pour être connu elle fait ça
parce que elle a plus rien dans la tête
dans le coeur c'est devenu un animal
vous entendez à la plus la route le
prophète aller cela dit celui qui n'a
pas de honte il va faire tout et
n'importe quoi tu apparente bah tu fais
des choses comme ça enfin là je me suis
habillé mon vêtement sur des steaks
on a certains ce dossier avant qu'ils
mangent dans la main qu'ils sont
inféodés aux tirs et les au dictateur et
n'est évident que les tyrans du monde
musulman n'est pas les musulmans puisque
amusé noir pas la démocratie c'est à
dire celui qui est au pouvoir doit être
choisie
n'est ce pas non pas être imposée il
doit être le meilleur le plus compétent
bref tous ces caisses qui doit être
celui qui va faire appliquer l'islam
point final mais vous savez très bien
que ces gens là il n'applique mines et
slam sur balmy sur la société donc le
brevet des vrais musulmans
s'opposent
au projet des tyrans et des spots des
dictateurs ça c'est du côté de nyon
après vous avez les non musulmans qui
tiennent les élèves de seconde les
algues et réaliste
colo/chi permettre de considérer
seulement comme des ennemis c'est
évident déjà effectivement les hauts
revenus dans les pays musulmans
respectifs ça a été la décolonisation
il donne une revue dit thiat en
entendant que je ne me plaît pas
et cette revue s'appelait le musulman il
écrit des articles dans d'exister
plusieurs visites et la revue de
l'association des étudiants musulmans de
france et m'a donné à l'article à lire
qu'il a écrit lui et c'est quoi cet
artifice et les musulmans découvert
l'amérique avant christophe
nous tous ou bien remplie notions
d'histoire les 492 étoffe que l'on
découvre des années c'est simple la
pinta la niña natta vous connaissez
l'histoire
moi je pensais d'articles est jolie et
qu'est ce que je découvre que nos
ancêtres les musulmans en
1250 et qu'elles sont parties de corps
tout d'ailleurs à court d'eau quand on
va y avait tout un quartier qui
s'appelait les musulmans de l'autre côté
de la mer des ténèbres ils ont pris le
bateau ils ont découvert les amériques
qui commerçait que les amis qui se sont
installés au brésil on a retrouvé dans
des grottes des versets du coran la
retrouver les monnaies des qualifs
d'espagne même elles sont partis aussi
du royaume du mali d'accord bref il ya
toute littérature historique une
musulmane prendre par l'histoire de nos
ancêtres
attention à tout ça c'est écrit tout ça
s'écrit ça existe mais on nous l'a
jamais dit n'est ce pas
j'ai déjà un âge donné à voir tu parles
22-23 cents
quand tu découvres saint tudy ah ouais
il était pas peut-être maison il est
plus intelligent que christophe huss
columbus
nature ce qui est bien c'est qu'il ment
découverte décembre d'abord dans les
deux sens entre les personnes quand
christophe si la découverte de son
arrivée une personne grâce à créer les
acca des aztèques des trucs machins et
en ramener des esclaves et là tu
découvres que tu as de quoi être fier de
son passé pas de quoi être fier de tes
en serre et pourquoi c'est quoi la
différence entre les musulmans qui ont
découvert les amélie et christophe c'est
quoi la différence
entre les musulmans et les autres
n'étaient pas musulmans donc pas de quoi
être fier d'être
vous avez compris le
et c'est vrai c'est une réalité
petite parenthèse anecdote c'est pas la
première fois que j'entends ce genre de
d'inepties sur l'amérique et il ya une
poignée d'années maintenant une femme a
écrit un livre qui explique que les
indiens d'amérique étaient en fait
musulman et cette personne a tourné dans
quelques mosquées en france pour
présenter son ouvrage
c'est dire le niveau de ce qui peut
tourner dans certaines mosquées chez
nous
oui là vous parlez plus de mixité la
mixité la mixité vous savez ce que c'est
c'est des hommes et des femmes dans un
lieu qui se respecte c'est ça la mixité
parce que thomas vous mélangez tout vous
pensez à la promiscuité
c'est à dire en est dans une pièce et je
suis assis à une femme à ma droite une
femme à ma gauche on et collés les uns
aux autres ça c'est pas bien ça nous
entendez mais si on est dans la même
pièce les femmes sont derrière les
hommes sont devant les hommes sans
droite les femmes sont à gauche c'est
pas marrant parce que pour qu'une chose
soir à mes fins versets du coran clair
et à un hadith authentique est clair yao
k hadith authentique est clair ni
versets du coran claire qui interdit la
mixité au contraire au temps du prophète
ce moment-là islam les hommes et les
femmes étaient dans la mosquée les
femmes derrière les hommes devant
des choses qu'il faut absolument
l'éviter lors des festivités
la première des choses c'est la mixité
en animal figo la publicité dans cette
situation ne veut être une grande année
pourquoi parce que c'est dans la nature
de l'homme et de la femme est deux fois
plus anciennes de la femme parce qu'il
ya des mariages le corps espèces sur son
31 2 0 c'est normal on est là pour se
faire plaisir et une femme quant à leur
public
quand l on zoome regard des amis
étrangers
doit avoir une tenue vestimentaire bien
particulière et il est évident que de
l'arrière c'est un enterrement
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire folie sur une
femme d'entre elles libres pour qu'elles
s'habillent quand même faible pour
qu'elles ne se fassent plaisir cette
soirée dans cette journée là sans
description quand même à nivelles c'est
pour cela on voulait un conseil le mieux
c'est une partager public en 2g de faire
par exemple des hommes l'après midi et
le soir les femmes est interdit aux et
vous mettre des videurs des bineuses par
l'anc n'est ce pas à l'entrée un des 10
aux heures d'entrées les femmes à son
entraîne comme ça sont dignes de faire
ce qu'elle veut et quand j'ai interdit
aux hommes d'entrée c'est les hommes
tous les hommes c'était bien même le
marier parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est à la
base le mari doit rentrer dans la salle
les pas reprendre des prêts ainsi marié
des avis il n'est pas là il rate dans la
salle rendez vous devant le peuple
organe élu et même les regarde et ça ça
se passait bien mais quand la belle fait
comme
c'est une seule acceptable
un minimum de jalousie un minimum de ré
la zambie et croyez-moi de pantin h du
mou dans ce domaine ça finit mal qu'est
ce que je dis ça film c'est déjà le cas
beaucoup de le mariage n'ont plus rien à
voir non plus avec l'autre religion mais
avec nos coutumes c'est un gros tube de
nos parents ou pas mal d'amis les
chevaux nos parents il avait de la
pudeur aujourd'hui la deuxième et
troisième génération comme mélanger les
garçons et les filles est elle une
retenue ya plus une pudeur ici c'est des
choses honteuses qui ne doivent pas se
faire leurs acquis doivent pas se faire
mal même si comme séparer les hommes des
femmes et laisser les faveurs de
s'amuser et laisser les hommes libres de
s'amuser comme ça on sort du mariage on
s'est fait plaisir on n'a pas désobéir
en pas et c'est ça le plus important
il est évident qu'en tant que musulman
ouais
je condamne
l'homosexualité
parce que nous la considérons comme un
péché
comme je condamne d'ailleurs la
consommation d'alcool parce que pour
nous c'est un péché comme je condamne le
vol et le viol alors que nous avons une
religion nous avons une spiritualité
nous avons une philosophie qui nous dit
qu'il ya des choses qui sont interdites
pour des raisons claires et nettes les
choses qui sont autorisés pour des
raisons claires et nettes donc chez nos
musulman l'homosexualité
qui n'est pas la bienvenue elle est
condamnée par les textes de manière
claire nette et précise
on est d'accord et j'ai le droit de
penser ça et je n'ai pas parce que je
pense et je crois que le mot sexualité
est haram illicite interdit c'est un
péché que je pars en croisade et je
cherche les homosexuels pour les pendre
c'est un raccourci qui n'a aucun sens
puisque ma religion me dis que
tous les êtres humains sont des pêcheurs
est bien d'accord que le blé adam ratant
deuxièmement
je ne suis pas investi de cette mission
qui est d'espionner de
fuir fouiner dans l'intimité des gens
pour savoir ce qu'ils ont pêché ils
n'ont pas pêché
et on a pas de barrière à écouter tout
le monde on écoute allemands toujours
avec l'esprit critique et nous prenons
de tout le monde ce qu'ils ont de
meilleur quand quelqu'un part j'écoute
je tamise tout simplement à l'assaut
raté des choses très intéressantes très
intelligente pertinentes et parfois on
peut très bien ne pas être d'accord avec
lui sur certaines choses pourquoi parce
qu'elle recevra c'est pas le bon dieu
comme le pape n'est pas le bon dieu
en vous à
complexer en vous faisant croire que le
travail et les efforts que vous
fournissez chez vous à la maison c'est
dégradant sa cdu simone de beauvoir way
qui dit que la femme doit se libérer des
tâches d'immanence
sais ce que c'est à dire les tâches
d'immanence les tâches d'esclaves
entre parenthèses langer les enfants
c'est changer des couches laver les
vêtements faire à manger nettoyer la
maison simone de beauvoir pour libérer
les femmes en prison chez elles qui
assument leurs responsabilités
[Musique]
a
proposé à ces femmes de se révolter de
se libérer de sortir pour aller
travailler dehors ouais elle vous a dit
bon c'est pas chez vous allez bosser
pour un patron d'or est juste une
parenthèse je vous renvoie une vidéo sur
youtube ça sert à quelque chose quand
même youtube vous tapez
libération de la femme
rockefeller
mois s'appelle les milliardaires les
états unis stockent faire autre chose
ils ont refait leur libération de la
femme pour un rockefeller points araud a
à bron rhône et vous allez voir le mec
il est ainsi et il parle et il parle du
mouvement de libération de la femme et
vous savez ce qu'il dit dans les années
50 nous avons créé le mouvement de
libération de la femme
[Musique]
j'entendais un
nouveau
avec les rockefeller les milliardaires
pourquoi pour deux raisons vous êtes
prêt pour que la femme sortent de chez
elles et calais y travailler
pourquoi est ce qu'ils voulaient que la
femme travaille dehors
il va le dire tant dès 22 heures il va
dire
ils dévoilent leur plan
qu'ils ont réalisé d'ailleurs c'est
pourquoi à côté ce qu'il dit il dit
c'est simple avant la société l'été
patriarcale ouais l'homme le père le
mari ibos
ouais il ramène ce qu'il faut la femme
et le mari ensemble géré la famille
chacun sa place
il dit
si on arrive à
faire sortir la femme de chez elles pour
qu'elles aillent bosser pour gagner deux
fois plus d'argent parce qu'elle va
avoir besoin d'une voiture pour qu'on va
vendre deux fois plus de voitures la
voiture à la besoin gasoil on va rentrer
deux fois plus de gasoil il ya des
réparations deux fois plus qu'à presser
je résume ce que le frère diddy cette
mentalité-là cette approche de la place
et de la question de la femme
est dû à quoi et eu une volonté de la
part notre société moderne et
matérialiste qui n'a plus mis au centre
de ses préoccupations d'intérêt de
l'humain mais plutôt l'intérêt
économique ouais
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
c'est pour cela qu'ils ont soustrait la
femme ouais à son rôle de mère il épouse
pour en faire une productrice dans la
société sous prétexte que le travail à
l'extérieur est plus gratifiant que le
travail à l'intérieur alors qu'en
réalité le travail de la femme à
l'intérieur comme tu le dit rien c'est
une lourde responsabilité
essai
c'est contraignant ouais mais c'est à
son honneur
tous
on n'existe pas on n'existe pas
politiquement
ici chez vous en ile-de-france la
communauté juive qui est organisée est
tant mieux pour elle ouais
ils ont des créneaux elle à sarcelles
vous allez voir à la sarcelle la piscine
de telle heure et elle aurait réservé
pour la communauté juive ce soit les
hommes se soient les femmes
voilà ils sont engagés
ils ont des droits ils se battent pour
les avoir et nos musulmans nathan qui on
attend
le m'a dit c'est ça si on attend auront
qui va venir avec son épée et d'un coup
d'épée tous nos problèmes sont résolus
donc si vous voulez aller à la piscine
engagez vous et je vous promets que dans
dix ans le problème n'existera plus
c'est pas
pas de l'alcool
la lapidation est elle vraiment autorisé
lors d'un adultère
sachant qu'on n'en parle pas dans le
coran la lapidation est elle vraiment
horizons en islam en france y'a pas de
lapidation donc pouvait dormez
tranquilles ok comment
tu as fait bah oui 90% des pays
musulmans tu te trompes d'affamés tu
dors tranquille c'est évident y'a pas de
lapidation maintenant est ce que ça
existe en islam est ce que ça existe
dans le coran dans leur a dit etc
j'ai envie de vous dire
ça existe ou n'existe pas ça change rien
puisque on est français nés en france
c'est plus un délit aujourd'hui ton
frais s'est trompé sa femme ses troupes
la femme n'a pas commis un délit en
france d'accord c'est même malade c'est
même recommandé ouais oui c'est à la
mode même nom mais c'est qu'est-ce qui
est aujourd'hui en franchise ou chez
certains et ça sera de plus en plus
c'est tu prêtes affamés nautiques près
de sa femme s'appelle les échangistes
c'est ça
donc c'est un faux problème ça comprenez
lapidation c'est n'existe pas ouais en
et français en en france point final
mais les ennemis de l'islam et bien
parler de ça
ouais une femme qui a été lapidé quelque
part et c'est soit disant ils ont pitié
entre nous et
c'est pas la femme qui doit être lapidée
c'est l'homme s'il a trompé sa femme et
qui a quatre témoins donc s'il le fait
en public
et c'est la femme elle l'a fait aussi
mais pas toujours lapider la famille
part jamais lapider l'homme faisait
remarquer pour vous montrer qu'ils sont
pas sincères qui cherchent pas défendre
la femme
tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est nous
embêter et faire fuir les gens de
l'islam d'accord mais en vérité un homme
s'il veut tromper sa femme
as tu peux rien faire il va à l'hôtel
des trucs de fait vous savez cette
histoire de lapidation c'est ce qu'on
appelle de la dissuasion
et
oui ces deux jours nous dit pas dix
mille choeurs pour le réformer au
ralliement oui il y bien sûr qu'elle est
mise en garde contre eux par les diables
parce que j'avais pas ne supporte pas
les savants qui craignent par mois
en moyenne 30 ans quand il était sur un
trottoir chaque année ce bar et il s'en
veut trottoirs
les élèves les descendants de remords a
passé la même chose
les hypocrites ne les supporte pas les
malades du coeur ne les supporte pas les
ennemis de l'islam ne les supporte pas
les combattent la preuve dans une pâture
hassan al banna kiseki la masse maigre
voulu y avait les allées comme vous le
savez vous savez pas les américains les
français les anglais les israéliens à 4
ans aurait mené dans une ville dans le
nord de l'egypte ils ont signé son arrêt
de mort et l'ont tué bien sûr la
maquille de la tuer c'est al arab sa
pelouse toujours les arabes qui le font
ouais le roi farouk qui donne l'ordre à
adele à adele et ils l'ont tué pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils vont tuer si c'était un
traître à l'hypocrite année gare et
c'est ce qu'ils auraient fait mais il
aurait mis sur un piédestal pour qu'il y
ait garde la communauté vous les prenez
pour des imbéciles des ennemis de
l'islam
[Musique]
vous avez vu regarder les gens parlent
et koné semaine paille par assemblée
savent même pas qui est ce alors gardons
et c'est un ennemi de l'islam c'est un
égal et si c'était à l'égaler il serait
la promotion d'un corps d'homme et matin
midi et soir comme ils font la promotion
d'autres pseudos l'imam al qardaoui la
haine c'est la bête noire
de tous les ennemis de l'islam
pour savoir qui errent dogan
les personnes à mon avis les mieux
placés pour en parler et pour nous dire
qu'ils t'il vraiment ce sont nos ennemis
tout simplement écouter ce que disent
les sionistes d'erdogan et vous allez
voir si c'est un bon si c'est mauvais
qu'est ce que disent les sionistes de
6,6
[Applaudissements]
c'est le meilleur c'est c'est la
bénédiction de dieu c'est une rare
masisi pour les sionistes et mais aussi
c'était quoi
c'était le diable bas erdogan c'est le
diable
ça va donc sheitan n'aime pas erdogan
donc automatiquement vous aimez erdogan
puisque vous n'aimez pas ce que je fais
est un noeud
m et vous détester ce que je fais est un
ne déteste rien que ça c'est suffisant
une petite mise en contexte simple pour
le prochain extrait qui est déjà
extrêmement long mais avant il y avait
encore une autre partie dans laquelle en
fait xn relaté donc l'histoire de moïse
et de pharaon et expliqué que qu'il y
avait un hébreu qui travaillait pour
farrar monde qui avait sa confiance qui
était son bras droit et qui en fait en
sous-main informé morizet les hébreux et
donc ce que vous allez voir la sueur sur
les élections c'est la suite directe
pour ça carrément il parle de pharaon
est ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
comme il le dit en fait c'est une
allégorie et qu'il faut bien comprendre
qu'en fait aujourd'hui faramond basse et
la société française c'est la démocratie
française est que les musulmans doivent
est très bien comme comme cette hébreu
un travail et à côté de pharaon pour
pharaon qui en fait travaillé pour pour
leur propre intérêt pour pour leur
communauté en sous main
parce que tu seras utile là où tu es
effectivement elle a été utile
sans transition
si vous savez lire entre les lignes
sinon dimanche vous devez être présent
là où il faut être présent pour dire ce
qu'il faut dire
oui des élections dimanche cantonales le
département
comme vous le sauriez pas le département
s'occupe des collèges le département
s'occupe des personnes âgées le
département s'occupe de toutes les aides
sociales oui
il faut voter pourquoi est ce qu'il faut
voter pour dire la vérité pour défendre
la justice vous devez voter pour
soutenir le meilleur des candidats vous
devez voter pour empêcher le pire des
candidats de prendre le pouvoir vous
devez voter pour exister politiquement
ne serait ce que pour que vous soyez
respecter
vous devez être présent dimanche
à côté de certains pharaon
serait ce que pour qu'ils tiennent
compte de votre existence et qu'il dit
me met un peu la pression sur vous
parce que
là et par des hommes politiques ne
comprennent qu'un langage celui des
urnes et le langage des urnes et
mathématiques c'est du comptage en fin
de journée
ainsi
c'est un devoir en tant que citoyen
d'améliorer notre société en mettant au
pouvoir des gens honnêtes des gens
sérieux des gens qui ont un esprit
altruiste
marc oui et c'est un gros problème
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui notre société occidentale
a tout fait pour que la femme ne joue
pas son rôle premier est fondamental
essentiel qui est d'être une épouse et
d'être une mère ensuite a peut être
médecin elle peut être journaliste elle
peut être ce qu'elle veut je m'en fiche
mais d'abord assumer son rôle de mère et
d'épousé
là
je vous invite à quoi tout de suite
discuté de ça
moi je veux une femme et je veux une
mère avec qui je vais partager mes jours
et on va mourir ensemble
qu'en dit le prophète vos agendas tous
qui one a aucune femme est venue dire
prophète qu'en est il de nos maris
comment je dois le considérer prophète
le dit c'est ton paradis ou tombant
faire
c'est ton paradis où ton en faire c'est
à dire si tu arrives à rendre heureux
cet homme tirant paradis sur terre et
dans l'au delà si tu fais la fal avec
lui tu vas vivre l'enfer ici l'enfer
dans l'au delà une femme est venue
questionner le prophète en fait qu'en
est il de nos maris c'est quoi leur
place chez ce qu'il a dit votre paradis
et au pied de vos maris
connaissez tous la fadette le paradis
aux pieds de là
labeaume qu'il existe un radis qui est
authentique way qui dit elle gêne neto
le paradis est au pied de vos maris
c'est un c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
le prophète seulement aller au samedi
saint
oui
tu t'es pas engagé à 100
tu veux tu veux tu veux revenir pas le
droit
tant pis pour l'absurde l'algérie
cerise sur le gâteau un bon musulman et
la france
non mais attends je me mets à sa place
c'est le top ouais
souvenez la télévision dans les années
70 ça va j'étais correct pouvait
s'asseoir en famille regarder une
émission garder un film regardé les
infos vous avez aujourd'hui ce que c
est qu est la première personne qui a
osé à la télévision
enfreindre
les règles de pudeur qui existait en
france car la france
était un pays de culture chrétienne
avec une morale chrétienne qui ressemble
beaucoup à la morale musulmane
la normale on a les mêmes références
c'est une présentatrice de télévision
j'ai même pas sur la carte danièle
gilbert
vous voulez
c'était la première qui a osé à la
télévision un passé avec une une jupe au
dessus du genou voilà ça a commencé
comme ça on a laissé faire et tout
doucement
à la diminuer et aujourd'hui vous voyez
ce que c'est
les jeunes qui meurent encore une fois
c'est un animal déguisés en humains donc
la personne elle passe à la télé et
c'est quoi son vêtement des steaks
quand
lady gaga c'est vrai ça va être comme ça
mais les gars
comme ça c'est
le porte bien
vous rendez compte
quand des comptes la bassesse jusqu où
elle va
si vous avez vu quand l'être humain n'a
pas de pudeur il fera quoi tout et
n'importe quoi est elle qui va se
comporter comme un animal il ya plus de
limites ouais
et regarder les sauvageons comment ils
se comportent aujourd'hui
notre jeunesse n'a
à partir de 10 ans
alors pour protéger la femme et la moe
si dieu nous dit
que chez votre beauté parce que il ya
des loups affamés
ça va vous coûter très cher vous les
femmes si jamais vous exposez votre
beauté en public parce qu'ils sont sans
pitié les hommes mais qui n'ont pas tort
ils sont sans pitié tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est profiter une fois qu'ils
ont profité up salah mouchoir à la
poubelle suivante suivante suivante
ainsi la tenue vestimentaire de la femme
musulmane c'est un bouclier c'est une
protection
des jeunes qui n'ont pas de limites
quand ils voient entre guillemets une
belle fille
il la drague qui la violent qui sifflent
etc mais quand une voix une femme dit
voile et
tout de suite
elle inspire le
respect pourquoi parce que déjà alors
fait pas coucou
et deuxièmement ils savent que mon la
seaal que sa beauté c'est qu'ils ont
donc c'est pas le voile c'est comment il
faut l'appeler
la mode islamique
la tenue vestimentaire
de la femme musulmane qui dit qu' elle
ne doit laisser apparaître quand elle en
présence d'hommes étranges et à les
proches n'ont pas sa famille proche les
étrangers à le donner sa part être que
son visage et ses mains au minimum
et si jamais on n'arrive pas à 100% -
80% c'est mieux que rien il est compris
ainsi elle n'arrive pas à s'habiller à
100% comme il faut
s'habiller à 75 en fonction de ses
capacités en fonction de sa possibilité
fonction aussi des conséquences
aujourd'hui dans notre société on
préfère les femmes à moitié nues qu'une
femme bien vêtu pourquoi parce que les
hommes sont mauvais parce que les hommes
sont vicieux parce que les hommes ne
respecte plus la femme
jerusalem la mosquée l arc ça c'est le
troisième lieu saint de l'islam la
mecque médine jérusalem ça fait 80 ans
que cette terre est souillée par des
despotes des tyrans
ça fait 80 ans que
le peuple palestinien
et l avant garde
et ils souffrent et nous n'avons pas le
droit de le laisser
seul face à ses bourreaux
qui sont sans foi ni loi
nous devons en tant qu'être humain en
tant que musulman être solidaire avec
les opprimés avec ceux qui souffrent sur
terre a fortiori avec ceux qui souffrent
sur terre dans la terre sainte pour
défendre
la mosquée sainte